JENNY MURPHY: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this session of the
Google+ Platform Office Hours.
Today we're doing something
a little bit different.
Instead of presenting some
content and talking about it,
we're going to focus on the
questions and answer section
that was normally the second
half of our Hangout.
Because there's a lot of
feedback that the people want
to ask their question.
So we want to devote
more time to that.
So just going to do
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You guys want to--
JONATHAN BERI: Well--
JENNY MURPHY: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JONATHAN BERI: Well,
let's do intros.
JENNY MURPHY: Oh,
introductions.
Good idea.
JONATHAN BERI: I'll start, since
I already waved my hand.
Jonathan Beri, developer
advocate on Google+ Hangouts.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm
Wolff Dobson.
I'm a developer programs
engineer on Hangouts.
JENNY MURPHY: And I'm
Jenny Murphy.
I'm also a developer program
engineer on Google+ platform.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I'm
Allen Firstenberg.
I'm a programmer.
I work [INAUDIBLE]
or for a Hangout API.
FRASER CAIN: My name's
Fraser Cain.
I'm the publisher of Universe
Today, and we've been doing a
lot of sort of cool,
live broadcasts,
using Hangouts On Air.
NICK GRACILLA: Well, hi.
I'm Nick.
This is Sonia.
We're at Neoteric Design.
We do web application design
and development, primarily
Ruby on Rails.
And we're using Hangouts
for training and for
collaboration.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
And, last but not least,
just saw that um--
Charles, you just joined.
CHARLES JAIMET: I did.
I'm Charles Jaimet.
I'm a developer.
I work for CalmSea Media, which
is my own company, and
I'm building an app in Hangouts
that allows people to
play games--
RPG games-- online.
Dungeons and Dragons-type
games.
NICK GRACILLA: Oh, right.
CHARLES JAIMET: To visualize it,
roll dice, do everything
in a shared environment
that you would
normally do around a table.
Fraser, actually, is part
of my little posse.
He's the one who dragged
me into this.
Gave me hours and hours
and hours of extra
work to do every day.
Thank you, Fraser.
JENNY MURPHY: Well, we're really
looking forward to
seeing what you come up with.
Most of the features are there
to support your goals.
CHARLES JAIMET: Well,
it's playable now.
We've been using it for
our weekly-- two
of our weekly games.
So anybody who wants to take a
look at it and give me their
feedback, I'd be more than
happy to give you a
walkthrough at some point.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sure!
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
Yeah, we'd like to see that.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
definitely.
JENNY MURPHY: So I guess we
might as well get into the
questions, now that
introductions are wrapped up.
So, does anyone in the channel
have a question they would
like to ask?
CHARLES JAIMET: I have
about seven.
JENNY MURPHY: Oh?
Tell us number one.
CHARLES JAIMET: Well,
number one.
Is there a limit to the
team size that you can
have in your app?
WOLFF DOBSON: There is.
It's not intimate.
I'm actually not sure what the
number is, but it will
eventually decide that
you've had enough.
But I think that number is--
let's see, I'm trying to think
of what the biggest
ones I've had are.
It's in the--
gosh.
I have to get back to you on
what exactly the number is.
I know, like--
100-ish.
CHARLES JAIMET: OK.
I had a little error for a
while, where I wasn't quite
able to correlate it to
anything, but I thought that
maybe it was the number
of people on my team.
I had around 20, 22, or 23.
And a lot of people were getting
a blue screen, they
weren't able to join the app.
And then once I dropped it,
the next day or two days
later, they were
able to get in.
But it might have been tied
to something else.
I wasn't sure.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, that's
interesting.
I know that if you add them to
the team while the Hangout is
running, it doesn't reboot--
it doesn't reload the ACL.
So I've had that problem,
where I'm like, quick!
I need you in this Hangout!
And I add them to the team, and
then I'm like, ah, I've
got to restart this Hangout.
So that can definitely happen.
But I'm not familiar
with why--
were they--
were these people in
distant places?
Were they in--
CHARLES JAIMET: Well, it's
probably just a coincidence.
Every week we play a game called
Apocalypse World, and
one week everybody was able to
get in, and the next week two
or three people got--
I think Fraser got in, but then
he couldn't see me, and
then everybody else couldn't
get in, and we
just got sort of--
what did you call it, Fraser?
The white screen of serenity.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, were you--
were you in Europe?
CHARLES JAIMET: One
guy was in Europe.
But he's able to get
in just fine now.
WOLFF DOBSON: Interesting--
there was a little bit of a
back-end thing that we kind of
modified about a week and
a half ago, that made,
basically, things that are
farther from Mountain View a
little bit faster.
So--
JONATHAN BERI: We improved
performance for remote locations.
WOLFF DOBSON: Thank you.
So that might have been part
of what you were seeing.
But, like I said, that would've
only affected Hangouts--
the Hangout's API stuff,
not the main Hangouts.
JONATHAN BERI: And in terms of
the team stuff, if you work
with any other Google APIs,
it's all sharing the same
infrastructure.
So not just the Google+, or
the Hangouts, App Engine--
they all share that same team
management API quota system.
And the limit on the amount of
team members is across all
products, it's not
just Google+.
I know 50 is not an unreasonable
team size, but a
couple hundred would be
breaking the bank.
Again, we're going to look back
and actually find out
what the real number is.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's
a good thing.
CHARLES JAIMET: I've only ever
got five or six people using
it at a time.
But because I want to start
running encounters, I want to
get as many eyes on this as I
can to see what people think
should be in there.
I'm putting people in, then
I'm taking them out
afterwards.
I guess I'm cycling
through people.
I can work with that
for the time being.
There was one little thing I
noticed, and I mentioned it in
one of the discussion boards.
When people hit the chat button
or resize the window,
it seems to trigger the on
participants changed.
WOLFF DOBSON: Hm.
Um, yeah--
CHARLES JAIMET: What
you code in there.
It was messing things up.
I fixed the code now, but it's
still calling that event.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's
interesting.
I know somebody was reporting
on the group that when they
resized the window, they
were getting a
participants changed thing.
I wasn't able to
reproduce that.
If you have code that does
reproduce that, please add me
to the team or send me the XML
link, and I will take a look.
Because again, the chat
thing is interesting.
CHARLES JAIMET: Let
me, actually--
WOLFF DOBSON: I'll just take
a look while we're talking.
CHARLES JAIMET: Yeah, in my app
we have a map, and the map
has a reset button that
puts everything
back to where it was.
You have tokens that you can
drag and drop to show the
location of various different
people, and when people were
hitting the chat button, it
was resetting the map.
Which was good, because it
showed me an error in my code,
because it shouldn't have
been doing that anyways.
It kind of buggered the map
for the whole game.
WOLFF DOBSON: I wonder if
that has to do with--
well, were you-- did you have a
whole bunch of people and it
was actually resizing the film
strip at the bottom?
Let me--
CHARLES JAIMET: Yeah, would--
certainly that would have been
happening, because when you hit
the chat, it changes the
available space.
And when you resize the window,
it also changes the
available space.
WOLFF DOBSON: Wow, you're
totally right.
Check that out.
It's on clicking the chat.
I don't see it on the resize,
but it totally
happens on the chat.
That is a great bug report.
I will take that back
to the team.
JENNY MURPHY: Thanks
very much.
CHARLES JAIMET: There you go.
JONATHAN BERI: You said you
have seven questions.
Keep on going.
CHARLES JAIMET: Well, I
don't want to take up
the whole time here.
I guess my big thing is-- and
I've asked this question
again, so I apologize
for asking it twice.
But I'm not sure that I got
an answer the last time.
I think the answer was no,
but I'll ask it again.
One of the things I'd really
like to have in my app is a
permanent data store for text,
tied to the players.
So there's the chat
window, which
doesn't seem to be permanent.
I'm not sure about that.
I can't create an activity or
write to an activity from the
app, or write to
the chat pane.
But what I'd like to do is--
there are a couple things that
people can do in the game.
They can write notes about the
game or they can roll the
dice, and I'd like to be able to
store that data so that it
can be pulled up later on.
JONATHAN BERI: So store data.
Interesting topic.
A lot of things we
can go into.
First of all, first question.
Does the data from one client
need to be available to
another client?
CHARLES JAIMET: The data needs
to persist from game to game.
JONATHAN BERI: Not
persistence.
So the shared state component.
So if I'm typing in text,
does somebody else
need to see my text?
CHARLES JAIMET: Yes, but I've
already got that worked out.
So the way that I'm doing
it right now is I'm
dumping it to an--
I'm using JSON and I'm dumping
it to my SQL database, and
then I'm pulling it
back out again.
And that way it persists
from week to week.
I just tag the game and it
doesn't matter if it's a
different Hangout.
You pick the game that you're
playing at the beginning of
the session, and you can pull
up last week's notes.
JONATHAN BERI: OK, so that's
persisting my own data.
So if Wolff and I are playing
together, and I type
something, and you store that
into my SQL, will he ever need
to read my data?
CHARLES JAIMET: Yes.
JONATHAN BERI: OK, so you need
also shared state across
multiple participants?
CHARLES JAIMET: Yes.
Anybody who's playing the game
should be able to see anybody
else's notes.
JONATHAN BERI: So have you
looked at the shared state
API, which is a JSON-like
feature?
CHARLES JAIMET: Sorry, yes.
But that only lasts to the
end of the Hangout.
JONATHAN BERI: Right, right.
So in terms of-- so shared
state is one thing, so
synchronizing across
participants is one piece, and
then persistence of data
is a second piece.
So--
CHARLES JAIMET: So the
shared state--
sorry, just to interrupt.
My understanding of the shared
state was there was a limited
capacity, around 10K.
Is that right?
JONATHAN BERI: Yes,
that's right.
CHARLES JAIMET: OK.
So that's why I've
been using JSON.
Because I end up with
too much in that.
And it eventually sort of dumps
data, or I have to dump
data myself.
JONATHAN BERI: I mean, it sounds
like you're doing the
right option.
There's the HTML5 local
storage kind of stuff.
It is a simple JSON
storage mechanism.
You can persist that on the
client, but if they're in a
different client, then it's not
going to be synced across
different browser sessions.
So, in reality, you're going
beyond the standard use case
of share state, beyond the HTML5
local storage stuff, so
you gotta store it somewhere.
CHARLES JAIMET: Right.
So my question, I guess, is that
the core of the Google+
system seems to be that I can
start an activity, people can
comment back, I can
limit it to just a
certain group of people--
but the moment that I go into
the app in the Hangout, I lose
that functionality which seems
to be core to Google+.
And I understand why you
wouldn't want an app writing
activities.
You end up with--
I mean, I'm assuming that the
rationale is that you'll end
up like Facebook, where
everybody with a Wordpress
website can post their blog
to their Facebook without
actually ever having to go into
Facebook, and that kind
of litters the landscape.
But it would be nice to be able
to use an activity that's
limited to the people who are in
the Hangout, and then pull
it up session to session.
JONATHAN BERI: Oh, OK.
So that's actually a different
question altogether.
You're talking about
write APIs.
CHARLES JAIMET: Yeah, I'm not
worried about the share state.
I've got the share state--
JONATHAN BERI: OK, OK.
So, that's a different story--
CHARLES JAIMET: Next week, I
want to be able to come back
and look at this data.
Six months from now, I want to
be able to come back and look
at this data.
I want to be able to carry
forward the notes from every
session into the next session.
JONATHAN BERI: Actually, we
can answer the write API
question, but before that--
it sounds like you're actually
asking for a different thing
than what you originally
formatted your question in.
If you want to see something
six months, nine months, a
year out, in a format that's
acceptable for your
application, actually using the
stream is probably not the
best solution.
You want a custom data store,
you want a custom storage
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So the way you're going about
it is probably the best for
your application.
Is it--
CHARLES JAIMET: It
works just fine.
I've got it working just fine.
It just seems that I'm kind of
reproducing what Google+
already does, it seems.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, but if it's
your own app-- so with
your look and feel-- you're
never going to have that same
control, because it's-- it'd
be through the Google+
activity stream, sort
of implementation.
Since--
it sounds like you're doing
it the right way.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
And I just pinged a friend.
It sounds like the team
size is about 50-ish.
JENNY MURPHY: Ish?
WOLFF DOBSON: Ish.
JENNY MURPHY: Wonder if you
can add aliases to that?
WOLFF DOBSON: You
can add groups--
JONATHAN BERI: No, you
can't add groups.
WOLFF DOBSON: You can add
groups, but it doesn't work
for Hangouts, I don't think.
I will get back to you on
whether groups is a way around
adding more people.
But the top level is, eh, 50.
JENNY MURPHY: 50-ish.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
Anybody else in the Hangout?
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, I think
Nicholas, you mentioned you
had a question?
NICK GRACILLA: Hi guys.
Can you hear me?
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
Loud and clear.
NICK GRACILLA: Thanks
for hosting this.
So, we've been using Google
Hangouts primarily for
training for our clients, and
we have some really basic
level questions.
The first issue we had yesterday
was with a client
who's in Beijing and
we're in Chicago.
And the connection just
got really sketchy.
And we had suggested that he
turn off his video, so we
could continue to
talk through it.
And that didn't really
work either.
So the first question is, like,
when the connections are
a little bit sketchy,
can limiting
video or limiting audio--
can that improve
the connection?
JONATHAN BERI: So, we're happy
to answer user questions, like
brief ones.
This is a developer office hour,
so we'll run through
your quick questions, and
if you have programming
questions, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
audience.
But for the short answer, we've
enabled a feature called
Connection Speed.
So within the configuration of
the Hangout itself, either
when you start up a Hangout or
any time in it, they can
switch it down to a slower
connection speed.
So the quality gets lowered,
but then it's
smoother video and audio.
JENNY MURPHY: Right.
And that feature's
accessible--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JONATHAN BERI: Pardon me?
NICK GRACILLA: That's the other
user's responsibility to
establish their own
connection speed.
JONATHAN BERI: Yep.
JENNY MURPHY: That is correct.
NICK GRACILLA: Awesome.
Thanks!
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, and I think,
experimentally, I did
turn off video from time to time
when I was debugging, and
it does actually improve
your roundtrip time.
But that--
I don't think there's science
back there, I just noticed
that myself.
CHARLES JAIMET: We had a game on
Saturday night and one guy
was dropping in and dropping out
and couldn't get it, and
he finally turned off his video
and he was fine for the
rest of the session.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
I think we have reports of that
working in the field.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
I think we can now switch over
to some of the comments.
We have two comment streams,
because we have
some questions from--
JENNY MURPHY: From before
the Hangout began.
We have some questions that--
JONATHAN BERI: Which one do you
want to start with first?
JENNY MURPHY: Your choice.
JONATHAN BERI: All right.
Let's do--
JENNY MURPHY: The
best question.
The most awesome one.
JONATHAN BERI: I haven't got to
the most awesome one yet.
JENNY MURPHY: Oh.
You can't sort by awesome?
JONATHAN BERI: There's no
sort by awesome filter.
That's the-- that'd actually
be a good demo.
Does anyone want to
put that together?
No, let's do the live ones,
because they're the freshest.
And the first one is a feature
request. On the product, how
about fixing the Linux hang-up
plugin download link?
Uh, if you could reply with
where the broken link is, we
could get the webmaster
to fix that.
Probably an easy one
for us to satisfy.
From Jennifer, will G+ allow
us to create custom URLs?
JENNY MURPHY: So by that
you mean, profile URLs?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I assume
they mean vanity URLs, but
that's a guess.
JENNY MURPHY: Vanity
profile URLs.
That's a great idea.
I've heard some requests for
that, but that's not
something--
I don't think any of us
actually know about.
In general, we don't really
talk a lot about future
feature releases, because things
just change here so
often that if we told you, by
the time the next week rolled
around, we'd no longer
be accurate.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, and
we want to give
you accurate stuff.
That is something you can
totally click on Send Feedback
and ask for, down in the
lower left-hand corner.
That is--
those people totally
read those.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, all--
not all--
you're not always going to get
a reply, but people do
definitely read everything
that goes
through the Send Feedback.
JONATHAN BERI: Absolutely.
And especially on the platform
stuff, which we are more
tapped to, feedback around
that we actually see.
So not only are the office hours
a great place, but click
that platform feedback button
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
yourself when you
come across it.
Question from Kyle--
we had a lot of feature
questions today,
not a lot on platform.
But happy to answer them.
Will strikethrough-- any Google
strikethrough thing--
work in Android iOS G+ apps,
work on web and mobile?
Yes, eventually.
We're working on getting the
feature parity in the web app
to the mobile app.
Obviously, we're working really
hard to give that web
app the core awesome experience,
and then there's
mobile teams both dedicated to
Android and iOS, making not
only those cool features work
in mobile, but also making
them optimized for the
mobile experience.
Expect, in general, them to be
catching up to the web app,
and also making its own
unique spin on it.
People trying to join
the Hangouts.
Oh, interesting.
Glenn-- can you create a
save-a-post-for-later option,
so that I can quickly peruse
through and hop back to save
area, for items that I want to
read but don't have time to do
right away.
WOLFF DOBSON: Ooh, it's like the
Watch Later for YouTube.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
Great idea.
I've seen people hack around
some Chrome extensions that
integrate with Google bookmarks
or other data stores.
Interesting idea.
We don't have that feature
right now.
I haven't seen a lot of
interest, but that's
definitely a cool thing to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] up to.
JENNY MURPHY: What I'm actually
doing to work around
that right now, since some
people ask some interesting
questions and it might take me
a while to get back to them,
is I'll just click on the little
date stamp in the top
of the post, which opens up just
that post in another tab
or window, and I'll just
bookmark that using my
browser's bookmark feature
and return to it later.
Which is really crude, but it
works surprisingly well.
JONATHAN BERI: And actually,
Dan suggested to Glenn.
Create a read-it-later circle
with no members, and then
share any post you want
with it, later.
JENNY MURPHY: That's
a great idea.
JONATHAN BERI: Pretty cool.
Andre asks, please let me block
users from the comment
right away, instead of having
to visit his profile.
And please make block user
comments invisible to me, and
please provide an API.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WOLFF DOBSON: --three or
four things in there.
JONATHAN BERI: Uh, there are
tools around managing spam or
unwanted comments.
We hear that.
Well, on the background, there's
bunches of people
working on the automatic
filtration spam.
So a lot of it you don't see.
In terms of just blocking
people that you're not
interested in, yeah, there's
always room for improvement.
Please use the feedback tool
for that kind of stuff.
That's exactly what
it's there for.
How do I make a picture
in G+ bigger?
Can you add an option to
like view in original
size or zoom in?
Right now, we just have
a download feature.
So if the author or the
photographer allows the
download feature, that's one
way to get around it.
When you--
the current UI, it's kind of
nice that it automatically
resizes for different browser
windows, so it
doesn't look funky.
But then you can't zoom
in with the standard
browser zoom features.
JENNY MURPHY: Right, and at this
time, the pictures are
actually-- if you use the
download link, if it's
available, the pictures are
actually available in up to
2048 by 2048 square.
Which is a pretty large size.
So it's not like the original
resolution of a raw image shot
from a 50 megapixel center,
but it's still a
pretty decent size.
So if you use the download
link you can see a pretty
detailed version
of that image.
JONATHAN BERI: Yes.
Sorry, I lost my spot.
Feature requests.
Would you like the ability to
synchronize a Google+ page
with an existing YouTube
and Picasa accounts?
JENNY MURPHY: So by
that you're--
we're assuming you're asking
you want the content that's
getting posted to a Picasa or
a YouTube channel, that you
already have established for
your entity, automatically
gets synchronized back to
your Google+ stream.
This is an interesting idea.
This is something that would be
great to send via the Send
Feedback feature, down there
in the lower corner, as we
mentioned before.
And we'll consider it.
JONATHAN BERI: Now, we don't
have a lot of synchronization
features across Google, with
regarding Google+.
But we have been adding
the +1 button.
So for example, in YouTube you
can +1 and share a video
directly into Google+.
We have that on Blogger.
You mentioned Picasa-- we
have it in Picasa also.
So that allows you to at least
get kind of there, by choosing
what you want to share into
Google+ pretty easily.
It's not full sync, but--
JENNY MURPHY: And there's
actually a reason that we're
taking that approach, is when
you share via the +1 button,
we give you the opportunity to
annotate and comment on,
provide some additional context
to what you're sharing.
And we feel that that provides
the highest quality experience
in the stream.
Because you can provide content
and that comment about
your video that just gives
people who are on Google+ a
little more context that they
may not have if they're not
already on YouTube.
JONATHAN BERI: I'm--
we're going to skip over some
of these feature requests,
because they're repetition--
WOLFF DOBSON: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JONATHAN BERI: Can you add a
voting app, or integrate +1 in
a way to make voting possible?
JENNY MURPHY: So voting is
something-- or polls on
posts-- are something I've
seen a few different
approaches to.
Some people are sharing external
voting apps, which
looks pretty cool.
Like they're just including them
in the stream, just by
sharing a link to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] or
something like that.
But within the application
itself, one approach I've
experimented with a few times,
is I'll create a post, comment
on it a few times myself with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], and then
disable comments on that post.
So then people can come and +1
the ones that they would like to
vote for, and that's-- it's
a simple pooling app, but it's
surprisingly effective.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, I've seen
that done numerous times.
I use that for my
own questions.
We actually just launched
something
kind of cool yesterday.
It went under the radar, but
with Google Docs, we now allow
you to share forms directly
into Google+.
And it doesn't--
it's not like a JavaScript
widget of any kind, but it
does some of the description
for the form, and that's
another way to do some sort of
polling or question-answer.
Cool.
You can share right
from Google Docs.
And we can link to that in the
[INAUDIBLE], the blog that we
talked about.
OK.
Oh, take a look at
Google Docs--
somebody.
Allen!
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY MURPHY: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: You beat
me to it one there,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JONATHAN BERI: What's that?
Yes, that's--
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: You
beat me to it,
announcing it on the Hangout.
JONATHAN BERI: This is true.
WOLFF DOBSON: All right.
What we got?
JONATHAN BERI: We have, why
can't Google+ and GTalk merge?
It is a pain to have
contacts to both.
Now, we have been introducing
elements of Google+ into
Gmail, and if you notice in the
Google+ version of Google
Talk-- so if you're logged in to
Google+ and there's a chat
going on, it shows the
relationships of people who
are actively in your circles.
And so, if you're in Gmail and
you see all your offline
friends, that's all great, but
in Google+ land, we only show
the ones who are actually
in circles.
So we're moving in
that direction.
And a comment on all
Google, right?
Google+ is about making Google
a better experience for all
our users by adding
social components.
So Google+ is going to be
part of that Google Talk
experience, it just-- we're
working through how to
optimize that.
So we're getting there, and
working on it, too.
Let's see.
WOLFF DOBSON: What
else we got?
JONATHAN BERI: Is there an API
that can have the latest
picture in an album displayed
first, or as a thumbnail for
the album automatically?
G Tan--
do you understand that, Jenny?
JENNY MURPHY: So it sounds like
you're asking for an API
that will allow you to integrate
the photos and
albums you have up there
with external sites or
applications.
The Picasa APIs offer limited
access to the photos now.
I'm not sure about
the details.
I don't believe there is the
exact features you're looking
for, but we're always looking
to expand more
Google+-centric APIs.
Photos are definitely something
we're thinking about.
So this is an interesting
feature that we will consider
when we revisit that later.
JONATHAN BERI: Yep.
Good question.
Will there be a connection
between Google+ for business
pages, places for business?
I think we've got this one a
few times already, but it's
still worth going over again.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, that's a
very interesting question,
because you think, Google
places pages and
Google+ pages look--
there's a lot of similar kind
of content on there.
It would be pretty cool
if there was some--
if those converged eventually.
But this is, again, kind of
a future-looking thing.
We don't really know
a whole lot about
what's going on there.
So not a lot we can tell you,
other than that would be
really cool.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, and in
general, the Maps business
pages have a use case, and
it's a different type of
application.
And the way it bubbles up in
Search is one way, and the way
we do the Plus pages and how
you engage your audience
directly through the Plus pages
for businesses, is right
now different.
And for good reason.
But definitely, there's
a world where we
could see those merging.
On-topic question.
From Gerwin.
He reported the discussions
are throwing some errors.
On-topic is, can someone explain
what the language
parameter really does in
activities.search and
people.search.
I wasn't able to see
a difference from
my last test queries.
JENNY MURPHY: That's
a great question.
It should be filtering by our
best guess of the language.
But it-- and you're reporting
that it's showing the same
results for all of them?
I"ll look back with you to
see what's up there.
That sounds like an interesting
issue that we
should probably fix.
Although, in short chunks of
text, sometimes it's difficult
to determine the language.
So it may be something
related to that.
I'm not really sure.
JONATHAN BERI: And as I
recall, we added the
enhancement to Search--
in the last year?
To allow you to filter
by language?
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, it's a
pretty recent edition.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, and I
believe its exact purpose is
the way you'd expect
it to behave.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, so it should
be a filter for the
content that you're searching,
such that you only load
content and results that match
the language that you specify
in that culture parameter.
But if that's not working, it's
something we need to fix.
So I'll go back with you.
Great question.
JONATHAN BERI: G Tan has a lot
of question-related API stuff.
Is an API to have custom slide
shows from photos in albums?
JENNY MURPHY: So this is--
it sounds like you're asking
about something similar to the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and the old
slide plug-ins that people
would use to do the slide
shows on their sites.
It'd be pretty cool.
We probably wouldn't--
I don't know that we would
expose a feature like that,
although we definitely could,
a component that you could
drop into your page or one
of the social plug-ins.
Another option that may exist at
some point in time is kind
of more raw REST APIs to provide
access to that data.
Neither of those exist
right now.
They may exist in the future
and would be pretty cool.
It'd be a great way to showcase
the content on your
page and profile.
But thanks for the idea.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, and
regarding to creating your
own, Jenny mentioned
the Picasa APIs--
those of you using your
old Gdata spec.
They're still pretty cool
if you're a Picasa user.
WOLFF DOBSON: You can
do a lot of things.
JONATHAN BERI: And you can do
a lot of things with them,
like build a slide show
widget from it.
And there's some pretty good
documentation around how to do
that, how to use
the Picasa API.
Let's see.
That was the bottom
of the live--
WOLFF DOBSON: Wait, Mike G. Is
there a plan to add multiple
email contacts to the Google
pages, so that every manager
can be notified about
a post or a change?
JONATHAN BERI: I think you mean
multiple admins for a
Plus page, because we have
that support now, right?
JENNY MURPHY: Yep, so if you
go onto your Plus page,
there's an option to manage
your Plus page.
And there's actually a list
of the pages that are--
the pages that exist. And from
there, you can actually add up
to 50 administrators per page.
And then all of them will have
all the capabilities of any
other administrator
on the page.
JONATHAN BERI: That includes
notifications, the little red
box, all the other fun
stuff we provide.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, which is
great for organizations,
because as time passes, the
people that manage that page
will change hands.
And eventually, none of the
original group may end up
working on a page.
But the page will live on,
like the rest of the
organization.
CHARLES JAIMET: I have a quick
question, if we're at the
bottom of the list. Is
there a way to--
I'm getting echo.
Sorry, just getting some
echo on my mic.
Is there a way to see how many
people have circled you back
in the API?
Or how many people are circled
and circled back to a
particular user in the API?
JENNY MURPHY: No, there's
no way to get to that in
the API right now.
But that's something that
would be really cool.
As you may have discovered,
it's already
on the profile page.
So it's something we'd like
to expose, but it's
just not there yet.
But it's on our list,
it's on our radar.
Good question, that would
be really cool.
CHARLES JAIMET: And back
to the Hangouts.
I asked--
I guess in the first-- well,
the first of these Hangouts
that I was aware of--
if at any point we were going to
be able to access the main
video window--
or the main video element, and
the thumbnail elements for
each of the people in the
Hangout from the app?
JONATHAN BERI: In terms of
more media APIs, that's
definitely an area that
we want to grow.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's something
we're really interested in.
JONATHAN BERI: The challenge,
but something we can overcome,
is the way the film
strip is done.
We're using the Google Doc
plug-in, which is a pretty
advanced piece of code.
It's C++ code, and we compile
it, we distribute it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
release cycles.
What it does is it actually
muxes all the videos on the
client side, which is why
we're allowed to do some
really cool multi-streaming
video.
But that-- the break it up part
and make that efficient
is something we just--
we have to work through.
WOLFF DOBSON: I mean, right now
we're rendering the film
strip as one big chunk that goes
plunk, and gets placed on
top of your thing.
So we don't have the ability to
knock those pieces loose.
But yeah, that is absolutely
something we're interested in.
JONATHAN BERI: And actively
investigating.
CHARLES JAIMET: And when
the Hangouts with
the apps come online--
I know you guys don't talk about
the future, so feel free
to say I'm not going
to tell you--
JONATHAN BERI: There is no
future, there is only the
past.
CHARLES JAIMET: It would
be really great--
Pardon me?
JONATHAN BERI: There's
no future.
There's only the past.
CHARLES JAIMET: It would be
really great to have them with
extras and with the On Air
capability, as well.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
Agreed.
So we could actually demo the
apps during office hours?
CHARLES JAIMET: There you go.
That'd be great.
Walk through an app with a
developer would be fantastic.
JONATHAN BERI: Yep.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're totally excited
about On Air.
As you know, it's in a
growing field trial.
It's already in the hands of a
lot of people, some of the
folks that are in
here have it.
WOLFF DOBSON: President Obama.
JONATHAN BERI: For example.
And as we're building up
infrastructure and the
quality, and we talked a little
bit about moderation
tools and things like that, and
as the platform matures I
would love to see a day were
they'd just be together.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, our plan is
definitely to have kind of
all the Hangout features
to converge over time.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] in the sake of
just getting features out
to people quickly, things have
kind of gone along--
WOLFF DOBSON: It's allowed teams
to work quickly, and
integrate quickly, but it does
mean that they have kind of
diverged a little bit.
Obviously you can see that
the UI's different
between the two and stuff.
So, yeah, but bringing those
together is definitely part of
the future.
JENNY MURPHY: Yep, that's
a big part of our plan.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
So G Tan asks--
it's two questions.
Two separate ones, but
I'm going to answer
them machine gun style.
The first one is, when will the
G+ games API be open to
the public?
So Google+ games is something
we're still
baking in the oven.
We have about 30-ish games.
You can see that on
the Games tab.
And we're working closely with
partners to really build out
what we want that API set and
what that platform to be.
It's an awesome part
of our product.
Millions of people play
games all the time.
And we're getting great feedback
in terms of features
and functionalities.
But that's a little ways off.
CHARLES JAIMET: I guess this is
another one of those areas
where you've get two groups of
people working in separate
rooms, but I'm building a game
app inside the Hangout API.
But it seems like it might fit
better inside the Games API if
the games had the video
component, as well.
Is that part of the plan?
JONATHAN BERI: Well, so--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JONATHAN BERI: We're biased,
because we work
on the Hangout apps.
WOLFF DOBSON: Hangout
apps are awesome.
JONATHAN BERI: The Hangout apps
and Google+ games are
kind of different beasts.
Games totally work in Hangouts,
but those games tend
to be tailored to utilize the
multi-player, the real time
component, the video
and the audio.
So if you're building a game
that leverages that video
piece, that probably belongs
in Hangout, right?
It's the other--
putting a game inside of a
Hangout, versus trying to put
the Hangout features
inside of a game.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah, but you
mentioned like a person
playing chess.
Right?
So you could have the video, you
could see your opponent.
You guys could be trashtalking
each other, but also moving
the pieces around on
the chess board.
JONATHAN BERI: Exactly.
And that's a Hangout
app that's a game.
Perfect use case.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
So I see that Mike just joined
the Hangout a few minutes ago.
WOLFF DOBSON: And he's typing.
JENNY MURPHY: He's typing.
So feel free to--
WOLFF DOBSON: --be a Hangout
gadget for iGoogle.
JENNY MURPHY: So feel free to
turn on your mic and join us
in the conversation--
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, it's OK.
He's chatting.
He's cool.
JENNY MURPHY: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So your question is, which
Wolff already read, and I
talked over him.
WOLFF DOBSON: Will there be a
Hangout gadget for iGoogle?
Hello.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi, Mike!
JONATHAN BERI: Right now, the
only place to launch a Hangout
on the web is from the
stream, and that
opens up a new IFrame.
And then for mobile, Android
and both iOS now supports
launching it from
Messenger app.
And that's all the plans
we have for right now.
So, not in iGoogle.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
WOLFF DOBSON: And the iGoogle
gadget spec is different than
the Hangout app spec, so
they're not really
overlapping.
JENNY MURPHY: So it wouldn't be
a core feature of iGoogle.
That's pretty unlikely.
JONATHAN BERI: So the last
question from G Tan,
at least for now.
Can you discuss how Google Apps,
Google App Engine would
work on G+ APIs?
More examples would
be helpful.
JENNY MURPHY: So Google App
Engine and the Google+ APIs.
If you've played with any of
our starter projects--
the Python or the Java ones--
you'll notice that our
examples-- or even the Hangout
one, the Hangout starter app.
Our examples all use
Google App Engine.
And there's a reason for that.
It's because we're familiar
with Google App Engine.
It's free to get started.
And we can give you instructions
that will get you
going pretty quickly, because
of that familiarity.
Also we're a little bit biased,
because it's Google
App Engine and the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] devpro team,
they're pretty cool guys.
WOLFF DOBSON: We think
it's nifty.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, we think
it's pretty cool.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, so if you
haven't checked out the App
Engine stuff--
WOLFF DOBSON: Python or the Java
App Engine starter stuff.
JONATHAN BERI: It'll get
you started right away.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, the starter
apps are-- which we'll
link in the show notes-- the
starter apps all-- they're App
Engine versions of all of
them, and very cool.
But the kind of connection
kind of ends there.
Other than the fact that Google
App Engines is in our
cloud, so you're going to get
pretty good response time for
APIs, it's pretty independent.
You can use the Google+ APIs
from any hosting provider that
you choose.
You just need App Engine
in our sample location.
[INAUDIBLE]
Fully independent.
But App Engine's awesome.
Check it out.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I've got a
question about image resources
and how they're used
in Hangouts.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sorry, can
you repeat that?
You're a little blurry.
Audio-wise.
JENNY MURPHY: A little
bit muffled.
Please repeat.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or type your
question into chat.
All's good.
Or your statement into chat.
Your question.
[LAUGHTER]
He says, "Aaagh!" We'll
emote for you.
Question about image
resources.
This is in the Hangout API.
So images-- for those
of you who are
following along at home--
you can allocate image resources
to use as face
overlays in the Hangout API.
JENNY MURPHY: Which is
a really fun feature.
It's a great way to get-- if
you're just starting with the
Hangout API, it's one of the
most instant satisfaction,
instant joy--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, I was going
to say, it's totally fun
to play with.
There's a nifty sample with
monocles and top hats that I
strongly recommend
you download.
The question about image
resources-- how much memory do
they use, since they can't be
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] or cleaned up
at this time.
At this time is an excellent
phrase to use there.
JONATHAN BERI: And--
keep going.
WOLFF DOBSON: And I've got an
app in progress that will be
allocating lots of graphics
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and then discarding them.
Yeah.
I think it depends a little
bit on how much memory the
plug-in is allowed
to use, because--
and that depends on your
system configuration.
In general--
I think I ran a test on
my MacBook Pro here.
And I allocated about 200 of
them before the plug-in was
like, all right, that's
enough, let's
just stop, shall we?
And right now if you run out
of memory, it actually just
halts the Hangout, which
is obviously not a
place we want to end.
That is under development.
But yeah.
Yeah, yeah--
it actually halts the Hangout.
Because you will have actually
run out of memory inside the
plug-in, which is what
it's going to do.
So yes.
Go gently on allocating those.
I think I had one that allocated
one about every
second, and it ran for
about 250 seconds
and then killed itself.
So that's not science, that
is field experience.
But yeah, it's in that range.
JONATHAN BERI: So, with
regarding to why it halts,
it's a pretty simple answer.
A lot of the Hangout API stuff
is handled by the plug-in, not
just the video stream.
So they're kind of
interconnected.
So as we make the plug-in
better, we make the Hangout
API better.
More performance, add
new features.
So one of the things, as a
result of our fun experiment,
was taking that feedback back
to the plug-ins team--
WOLFF DOBSON: We were like,
hey, look at this!
JONATHAN BERI: So garbage
collection improved, resources
swapping out improved.
So they're taking that, and
they're going to work that
into the next plug-in,
which means they have
more stuff for API.
NICK GRACILLA: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN BERI: You're
welcome, Nicholas.
Nicholas says thanks.
Let's go back to the posts.
Blah, blah, blah.
[INAUDIBLE]
translation.
G Tan, you're just full
of questions today.
I wish I knew your first name.
Unless it is G. Is there a way
to call functionality in the
G+ Android app via another
Android app?
Hm.
JENNY MURPHY: So you're thinking
of-- like in Android
we use intents pretty heavily
to communicate between
applications.
So one of the ways this may
work would be to create
intents that would cause
things to happen in the
Google+ app.
We don't have any
of those yet.
But it's something we're
actively working on, and when
we have it ready, it'll
be really cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: Does our starter
Java project cover--
it covers basic Android,
right?
JENNY MURPHY: So the Java
starter for the Google+ REST
APIs includes an Android
application, in addition to a
command line, a generic web
application, and a Google App
Engine sample.
And the Android sample shows you
how to interact with the
Google+ REST APIs from Android
in a nice way.
So you can write neat Android
apps that use the read APIs.
But that does not interact
with the existing Google+
application on the device.
That would require us to expose
hooks so you could
interact with that, and those
are not available yet.
But it's something we're
figuring out.
We're going to have a plan.
It'll be really cool.
Hang tight.
WOLFF DOBSON: One of the
questions was, do we have a
way to automatically
shift languages?
JONATHAN BERI: Translate.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
Sorry.
Shift-- it's like magic.
Drop in another language.
That'd be cool.
You should add that
to Send Feedback.
And then also, I think there
are Chrome extensions out
there that will let
you shift pages--
translate pages using the
Google translate thing.
If you're getting
hung up right--
send Feedback, but if you're
getting hung up right now, you
should investigate
some of that.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, if I
remember right, I believe I've
actually seen someone playing
with a Chrome extension that
added translation features
for individual posts.
And it can definitely--
if it doesn't-- if it's not out
there, it could definitely
be written.
WOLFF DOBSON: Absolutely.
Yeah, you could write it, too.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, this could
be a cool project for you to
come write and show us.
JONATHAN BERI: There is one.
I don't have the name off the
top of my head, and there
might be a couple.
One bundled up with a bunch
of other features.
But we can check it--
I'm sure some people in
the Hangout already--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, you guys can
probably go-- probably are
able to use a search engine
to find that.
JONATHAN BERI: But yeah.
So Google+ is an international
product.
We support a bunch
of languages.
It's just the cross language,
cross locale piece of it, is a
bigger challenge
in translation.
Especially just words, because
you have other pieces that are
not translatable, like
GIFs and images.
So we're working on that, as an
international product and
an international company,
to make that a priority.
JENNY MURPHY: I agree, it's
pretty cool when you watch a
stream, and as the
clock turns--
you can see the clock passing in
daytime in Asia, and all of
the sudden the posts start
coming up in languages that I
can't read.
WOLFF DOBSON: Definitely.
JENNY MURPHY: Very neat.
JONATHAN BERI: So we're
hitting 12:16.
That's usually when we try
to wrap things up.
JENNY MURPHY: So are there
any questions from the
participants?
WOLFF DOBSON: We don't wrap up
at 12:15 because it's not a
factor of two.
JENNY MURPHY: And
last questions?
Or is there anything else
on the [INAUDIBLE]?
WOLFF DOBSON: I think
actually that's--
JONATHAN BERI: We--
a lot of the--
I think we're good.
JENNY MURPHY: We're good.
So well, we've answered all the
questions we found during
the duration of the Hangout.
This was a lot of fun.
Thanks to everyone who
joined the Hangout.
We will-- oh wait, there's one
quick question that just
showed up in the chat, which
we will address.
One more quick question,
asks Mike,
about the iGoogle gadget.
Can you add a +1 to
a gadget page?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, to the
add gadget page.
JENNY MURPHY: The
This is a good question.
WOLFF DOBSON: I don't know.
JENNY MURPHY: I believe
you've stumped us.
WOLFF DOBSON: We are not
familiar with that.
JONATHAN BERI: So I think the
question is, for the existing
gadgets that we have in our
iGoogle gallery, can we add a
+1 to each one of the
gadget listings?
JENNY MURPHY: Oh, it that
what you're asking?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
like this page.
JENNY MURPHY: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the gadget gallery?
That would be really cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, that's
an interesting idea.
JENNY MURPHY: We will definitely
relay that feedback
to the iGoogle team.
We like the +1 button and we
want it to be more places.
WOLFF DOBSON: Putting it on our
own product seemed like an
excellent choice.
JENNY MURPHY: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that.
JONATHAN BERI: And even today,
we don't have the +1 button
there, but we have the Chrome
extension that allows you to
+1 yourself any page
on the web.
And, of course, if you find
pages in the search results on
Google, you can also
+1 it from there.
So we do collect those
+1s, even if it's not
directly from the site.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
Well, we will be wrapping it
up for this week then.
Thanks to everyone who
joined the Hangout.
And thanks to everyone who asked
questions, whether you
joined to ask questions or you
asked questions on the posts.
And we will be back next week
to answer questions and show
you some cool stuff on
the Google+ platform.
CHARLES JAIMET: Thanks a lot,
Jenny, and everyone else.
JONATHAN BERI: Thanks, guys!
WOLFF DOBSON: Bye!